hi everyone
this is professor mda science and today
i want to talk about coherent states of
the quantum harmonic oscillator
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics coherent states are
defined as the eigenstates of the
lorrying operator today we'll look at
two fundamental properties of coherent
states the first
is what they look like when we write
them in the energy basis
and the second one is the time evolution
this will prepare us to study the hugely
important role
that coherent states play in quantum
mechanics and you will be able to find a
full series of videos by following the
links in the description
asatisa coherent states are the states
that most closely resemble
the classical motion of a harmonic
oscillator and they also play a key role
in the quantum theory of light
so let's go our focus today is on the
coherent states of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
so let's start with a quick refresher of
this very important system
the hamiltonian h of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
has a kinetic energy term and a
potential energy term
that is proportional to the position
squared
we can also write down this hamiltonian
in terms of the lateral operators
a dagger and a or in terms of the number
operator
n this is the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian
where as usual these are the eigenvalues
and these are the eigen states
the eigenvalues are equal to h bar omega
times n plus one over two where n
is a non-negative integer zero one two
and so on
so today we will mostly work with the
lateral operators
the lowering operator a and the raising
operator a dagger
the ladder operators allow us to move
between eigenstates
and to see this more clearly let's draw
the real
axis and place some of the allowed
energy eigenvalues
on it each of these is associated with a
corresponding
energy eigenstate acting with the
lowering
operator on eigenstate n gives a new
term that is proportional to eigenstate
n
minus one and the energy of the state
has decreased by
one quantum h bar omega conversely the
raising operator acts on eigenstate n
to give a new term proportional to
eigenstate n plus one
raising the energy of the state by one
quantum
so this is our refresher on the quantum
harmonic oscillator
but you can follow the links in the
description for all the details behind
these concepts
okay so we're now ready to define a
coherent state
coherent states feature in a variety of
areas and
those associated with the quantum
harmonic oscillator are sometimes called
canonical coherence states to
distinguish them
from the others i'm going to use
the simpler term coherence states but
just be aware
that you might find this slightly
different terminology in the literature
okay so a coherent state alpha is
defined as an eigenstate of the lowering
operator
in this expression this is the
eigenvalue and this is the eigenstate
as the lowering operator is not a
hermitian operator
alpha is in general a complex number
what does it mean conceptually that
coherent states are eigen states of the
lowering operator
an eigenstate is a special state which
doesn't really
change when you apply the corresponding
operator all that happens is that you
may get
a scaling factor the eigenvalue
but remember that the application of the
lowering operator on an energy
eigenstate
removes a quantum of energy and so given
this
it may appear somewhat strange that the
lowering operator can have eigenstates
at all
as removing quanta of energy should
definitely change a quantum state
right well we will next build an
explicit expression for a coherent state
that will help us make sense of this
to do so we will write the coherent
state in the basis of
eigenstates of the hamiltonian let's
write a general expression of a
coherence state
in terms of the energy eigenstates of
the quantum harmonic oscillator
as usual the expansion coefficients are
given by the bracket
between alpha and n and i'm writing an
explicit dependence on alpha to
highlight that they may be different
for different coherent states let's now
consider the action of the lowering
operator on the coherent state
expanding the state in the energy basis
we get this
we can move the lowering operator inside
the sum
and obtain the sum over these terms
now remember from the video on ladder
operators
that for n larger than or equal to 1
the lowering operator acting on an
energy eigenstate
gives another energy eigenstate with one
fewer energy quantum
and for n equals zero the lowering
operator acting on the energy eigenstate
kills the state using these results we
can write
that the action of the lowering operator
on a coherent state
is equal to a sum over the expansion
coefficient
square root of n and the energy
eigenstate n minus one
note that the sum now starts at n equals
one because we've killed the state at n
equals zero
but n is just the index of the sum so it
is a dummy index and we can replace n
by n plus one to conclude
that a acting on alpha is equal to this
expansion
where the sum again starts at n equals
zero
to continue with our derivation for an
expression of a coherent state in the
energy basis
we next need to remember that a coherent
state is an eigenstate of the lowering
operator
then we can use this expression up here
that we've just derived
to rewrite the left hand side like this
and the right hand side is equal to the
eigenvalue times the eigenstate which
i am also expanding in the energy basis
moving all terms to the same side we get
sum of ren
of the term proportional to the n plus
one coefficient
and the term proportional to the n
coefficient
all acting on the n eigenstate
and all equal to zero this will only be
true if all terms in brackets
vanish for any n so that we get a
recurrence relation
for c n plus 1 in terms of c
n this relation is true for any
n so we can now iterate and write c n
in terms of c n minus one
and so on we can rewrite
this expression using the c and
coefficient as a starting point
and iterating all the way to c0
we can combine these three factors to
this single term
times c0
and we now have all the ingredients to
write a coherent state in the energy
basis
we can expand the coherence state with
the standard expansion
and using the expression up here for the
coefficient cn
in terms of the coefficients 0 we can
then rewrite this expansion as a sum
over in
of these scalar factors
times the corresponding energy
eigenstate
this means that all we need to fully
specify the coherent state in the energy
basis
is to determine the value of c0
as you may have guessed we are going to
use normalization
to fix c0 we insist that
1 is equal to the sum over the absolute
value square
of the coefficient and we can now insert
the expression of the cn coefficients in
terms of the c0 coefficient
this term does not depend on n so we can
take it out of the sum
and we end up with this
this sum here is now the power series of
the exponential of the absolute value of
alpha squared and we end up with the
absolute value of c
0 squared times the exponential
this means that the absolute value of c
0 squared
is equal to this exponential to
determine c0
we need to make a face choice the
conventional choice is to make
c0 real and positive so we end up with
this
and with this we can now write the
coherence state in the energy basis
using this expression we derived up here
we can copy it to write
that for coherent state can be expanded
in the energy bases like this
we can then use this expression we just
write here for c0
to end up with an exponential factor
multiplying the weighted sum
over the energy eigenstates
and this is the final expression for a
coherent state
in the energy basis
so what can we learn from this explicit
expression for a coherent state
again remember that the eigenstate of an
operator is a state
that at most changes by a scaling factor
when we apply the operator on it a
coherent state is an eigenstate of the
lowering operator
which implies that the application of
the lowering operator should not
change the state apart from a simple
scaling
but we know that the action of the
lowering operator on an energy
eigenstate
removes an energy quantum so how can we
rationalize this this coherent state up
here is a superposition
over all possible energy eigenstates
so essentially a superposition over an
infinite number
of energy eigenstates when we act with
the lowering operator on it
for every term in the sum we remove one
energy quantum
but the form of these expansion
coefficients is such
that every term becomes exactly equal to
the original term
with one fewer energy quantum so that
the overall state
does not change this is enabled by the
fact that the sum
is infinite so there is no such thing as
a
highest energy state that we cannot
recover
after applying the lowering operator
another interesting point to note is
that coherent states are associated with
the poisson distribution
if we have a quantum harmonic oscillator
in a coherent state
then the probability of measuring a
particular energy level n
is equal to the corresponding expansion
coefficient squared
using the expansion up here we can
insert the value of the expansion
coefficient
and we can simplify this expression to
this
this is indeed a poisson distribution
and
this property has important implications
for example in the field of quantum
optics
it means that coherent states of photons
can be split
into other independent coherent states
something that can
only happen with what's on statistics
but in this video we're going to simply
leave it as a neat observation
and move on for now
now that we understand coherent states
let's investigate the time evolution
the first step is to realize that the
hamiltonian of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
is time independent and remember
that a system for which the hamiltonian
is time independent is called a
conservative system
from the video on the schrenninger
equation we know how to evaluate
the time dependence of a conservative
system
so let's imagine that the initial state
of our system
psi at time 0 is equal to
a coherent state alpha zero
we can then write it in the basis of
energy eigenstates as we derived a
moment ago
it is equal to this exponential
pre-factor times
this infinite superposition of energy
eigenstates
what does this state look like at a
later time
for a conservative system the state at a
later time t
is equal to a very similar superposition
of eigenstate
with the exponential times the infinite
sum
over elegant states
the only difference is that now each
eigenstate is multiplied by
this term here a phase factor that is
proportional to the corresponding energy
eigenvalue
in our case the energy eigenvalues are
those of the quantum harmonic oscillator
so we can rewrite the state at time t
as equal to the exponential pre-factor
and then the sum
over eigenstates where i am including
the explicit form
of the energy eigenvalues of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
the part of the exponent associated with
this one-half here
does not depend on n so i can take it
out of the sum
and then we have the usual pre-factor
and then i am rearranging the remaining
terms in the sum
feel free to pause here for a moment if
you want to cross-check this final step
so let's recap if the initial state
of the system is a coherent state here
then this here is the latest expression
that we got
for that state at a later time t
i'm now going to define the complex
scalar alpha
as equal to alpha 0 times e to the power
of
minus i omega t it then follows that the
absolute value squared of alpha
is equal to the absolute value squared
of alpha 0.
using this definition we see that we can
replace
this term with alpha and we can also
replace
this term here by the absolute value
squared
of alpha this means that we can rewrite
the state of the system at time t as
equal to this phase
multiplying this exponential pre-factor
and then multiplying the
infinite sum over energy eigenstates
this whole expression now has the form
of the coherent state
alpha and this means that we can write
the state of the system at time
t as equal to this phase factor times
the coherent state alpha
and this is true for alpha equal to
alpha 0
times the exponential of minus i omega t
now what does this mean if the initial
state of our system
is a coherent state that is an
eigenstate of the lowering operator with
eigenvalue alpha 0
then the state of the system at a later
time t
is equal to this global phase factor
times a new coherent state which is an
eigenstate alpha of the lowering
operator
corresponding to eigenvalue alpha 0
times the exponential of
minus i omega t and remember
that a global face factor like this one
here does not
change the physics this takes us to the
key result
relating to time dependence a coherent
state
states coherent at all times
right so this is it for coherent states
but before we finish
let's discuss one final thing given that
coherent states are defined as the
eigenstates of the lowering operator
a natural question to ask is well what
are the eigenstates of the raising
operator
a dagger and it turns out that the
rating operator has
no eigenstates to see this let's write
down a tentative eigenvalue equation for
the racing operator
where i'm using lambda for the
eigenvalues here and also for the
eigenstates here
let's now consider the expansion of the
eigenstate in the energy basis of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
where as usual the expansion
coefficients are given by this bracket
we now want to evaluate the eigenvalue
equation for the raising operator using
these results
to do so let's start with the left hand
side a dagger acting on the expanded
eigen state
we can move the raising operator inside
the sum
and using the action of the raising
operator on an energy eigenstate
which is equal to this prefactor times
an energy eigenstate
with one additional energy quantum
we can then rewrite this term as equal
to the infinite sum
over c n times the square root of n plus
one
times the energy eigenstate n plus one
going to the full eigenvalue equation up
here we can now write it in the energy
basis as this left hand side we just
derived
equal to the eigenvalue times the energy
expansion
of the eigenstate
let's make some room and let's copy the
latest expression that we got for the
eigenvalue equation
of the raising operator in the energy
basis
as the different energy eigenstates are
orthogonal then this equality
will hold if the coefficients in front
of each of the energy eigenstates
match on both sides so starting
with the ground state there is no ground
state in the left hand side
and the coefficient is lambda c 0 in the
right hand side
so we get that c 0 must equal 0.
for the first excised state we get c 0
from the left hand side
and lambda c 1 for the right hand side
as c0 is zero then this implies that c1
is also
zero repeating this argument for all
terms
we get that for the nth excited state
the equation looks like this
and as the previous step showed that c n
minus 1 vanishes
this implies that c n also vanishes
we therefore conclude that the
eigenvalue equation for the rating
operator will only be true
if all expansion coefficients are zero
this implies that the only solution is
one for which the eigenstate is equal to
zero
and this means that the rating operator
has
no eigenstates this result
is actually relatively easy to
understand conceptually
when we write any state lambda in the
energy basis
then there will be an eigen state in the
expansion that will correspond to the
lowest energy of all eigenstates
i will call this lowest energy
eigenstate and min
this may be the ground state itself or
another state
when we apply the raising operator on
lambda
then each eigenstate will turn into a
new eigenstate with an additional
quantum of energy
and this means that in adage lambda the
lowest energy eigenstate is n min
plus one this means that the lowest
energy eigenstate in the new state will
have one extra quantum of energy
compared to the original one
so that the new state a dagger lambda
can never be proportional to the
original state lambda
this intuition confirms that there
cannot be
eigenstates of the rating operator
note that these results are consistent
with our discussion about the lowering
operator
which does have eigenstates they are the
coherent states that we've been
discussing today
this argument that we just put forward
for the racing operator does not apply
in that case
because a coherent state has no state
with a highest energy
because the sum is infinite and this is
the reason that we have eigenstates of
the lowering operator only
as a final comment you may be worried
that the raising operator has no
eigenstate
but this is actually okay because the
rating operator
is not a hermitian operator
in summary and in the context of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
we've defined coherent states alpha as
the eigenstates of the lowering operator
we've also found that we can write these
coherent states in the energy basis as
shown here
and the expansion includes all energy
eigenstates
and finally we've shown that if the
initial state of our system
is a coherent state then the state of
the system
remains coherent at all later times
we now understand coherent states as the
eigen states of the lowering operator
but what makes coherent states
interesting goes well beyond that i
encourage you to follow
our series of videos on coherent states
in which we will explore among other
things
third relation to classical mechanics
coherence states also play a fundamental
role
in quantum optics for example for our
understanding of lasers
and as always if you liked the video
please subscribe